we got a vote I'll start Rudy Gobert
well yeah all-star yes but if we're
talking Defensive Player of the Year the
reason why bowler is I think he's to me
he deserves it he should be the guy what
eight year old this is his first trip at
this level but you can see as mental on
the cross a fan little hero on his web
the basket everyone to their feet they
appreciate the hustle
they appreciate the effort now avoid any
fouls
Mitchell how alert is he off the glass
for the Australian firemen's that are
the relief efforts in Australia Ingram
on the run Brandon Ingram has the right
thought process I'm not going to to
round the shoe floaters I'm going to the
rim to attack of him there's the show so
the shot clock though bratter de-growth
he's got the clock in front of us she's
got a hand on the ball prison hard hat
every single game and does the little
things to help win basketball game
Derrick Favors I'm preferring to deep
Donovan Mitchell Jan's that kid talented
Boise helps being in help position right
Mitchell sees the clock
it's going to be a triple that was up
against their best defender on the
perimeter Royce O'Neal you got the
screen he wanted kind of protect it on
the fall away
108 104 grew up up to 34 SK between
these two is 18 a fast break points Utah
tonight it's 23 sick spells taking
advantage as Donovan Mitchell lateen
quick side go fair clears it away
they've got numbers that they want them
angles with Bogdanovich and bitch'll for
the lead look at one a 111 108 you saw
it coming and once again giving us
everything you know what's coming do you
know what's coming that's what's that
man with the basketball right now said I
can you know what's coming
Ingram's mid-range right back out Josh
hard body a 3/4 Ingram second-chance
opportunity give him the rock and let
him go can you snap their 10 game
winning streak
did you slow this guy down
off the dribble in rhythm again enemy
Ingram I'm against O'Neal they'll get it
to Brandon Brandon with two on the clock
for the win
[Applause]
as we watch the replay I said you would
that's Pete what are we saying the
beginning of the game because the way
they do so exam guard that pick-and-roll
Brandon Ingram understands you can
forgive right so Naomi you can put back
down a bit Tommy you can put gel angles
on me I can feel get to my spot and
elevate he has been bent 6:15 and even
better in the ticket has been on the
floor a lot in the second half he had
one break in the fourth placed the
entire third he'll take the three and
getting the four points 11 boards for
Derrick Favors
you put it drafted and taking it out of
his hands and daddy's going to get a
runner